puisqu'on parlait de musique gros plan à
présent sur une des têtes de file du
rock alternatif français un groupe à
part depuis plusieurs années hors des
circuits de distribution des grandes
compagnies je veux parler des garçons
bouchers
le groupe parisien vient d'entamer une
tournée française juste après
l'enregistrement de leur dernier 45
tours son titre du beaujolais mais
ancien mari tombe toujours présent non
tirées à partir de là nous avons
remplacé par sablé senti et puis comme
on s'était dit que quitte à changer
autant évolué on fait rentrer deux
cuivres
quant aux rares ou trombone et c'est là
ça ne me touche stéphane aux allophones
les garçons bouchers sont considérés
aujourd'hui comme les leaders du
ternes actifs et indépendant du rock
français chef d'une file un peu
particulière où on peut trouver des
groupes comme oth les vertes
et la mano negra avant qu'elles ne
signent dans une grosse maison de
disques
les garçons bouchers célèbre grâce au
rap du même nom quand attaquer le marché
au milieu des années 80 à une période où
les productions françaises se chercher
hésitant entre une variété musclé et à
rock cyrus veut le mouvement alternatif
montrait alors les dents la belle à
l'appui boucherie productions mais pour
les garçons boucher les oreilles
françaises sont encore un peu hermétique
je pense que mme dati c'est ce qu'on
appelle alternatif et indépendant marche
pas si mal que ça en france il ya ce
qu'il a du mal à passer le cap
enfin tous les que tous les facteurs
pour qu'ils passent ce cap supérieur
sont sont résolus et que je pense que
c'est pour 90 kw h en chanson française
ne peut rien à lire donc qui peut
remplacer la chanson française mutuelles
rock français maintenant personne
la mae mobifrance quoi
jours
voilà
audi
à st-gall
en fait
à voir
ouais
bon